If you’ve ever been stung by a jellyfish,
you know that their sting can pack a mean punch.
That stinger is actually a tiny missile
launched from a cell on the jelly’s tentacle
Both microbes and cnidarians
such as jellyfish,
wield these harpoon-like weapons
called nematocysts.
Microbes like dinoflagellates,
have evolved their own arsenal
of these tiny weapons.
This is polykrikos kofoidii
hunting for dinner.
We’ve known for almost 100 years
that these miniscule creatures
were hunting and fighting with weapons
but thanks to new technology
we can now observe them in stunning detail.
Using focused ion beam scanning microscopy,
researchers imaged and modeled
two different dinoflagellates.
They found that their nematocysts
are surprisingly sophisticated when compared
to their animal counterparts.
Even though jellyfish nematocysts
are 20 times larger,
they have far fewer moving parts.
In polykrikos kofoidii,
each nematocyst
is made up of a capsule
with a stylet nestled inside.
When they sense their prey is within reach,
they fire off the stylet,
bursting through the operculum,
and literally tow their catch in to eat.
Then the tow line dissolves.
Researchers also studied another type of dinoflagellate
that employed a “gatling gun”,
with 10-15 stylets arranged in a circle.
Despite the similarity to nematocysts
found in jellyfish and its relatives,
one is not derived from the other--
they evolved independently.
In fact, the ancestors of dinoflagellates
were photosynthetic, relying on the power
of the sun to create energy.
Over time, that they lost their ability to
harness the sun’s energy
and became full time hunters.
Now, they’ve spent millennia
honing their
weapons,
gearing up their gatling guns, and
gathering their defensive goo...